[Applause]
well welcome back
uh i i won't use the word exclusive
because that's kind of kitschy
uh but we've got some serious
serious fist pumping going on because
we've got tobias lefkovich with us today
i i almost want to say he needs
no introduction uh he's been
city's chief u.s equity strategist for
years just just had your 20-year
anniversary
but i can't thank you enough for sitting
down with me
um today welcome thank you very much
danielle it's great to be here
so um you know i've only known you since
2005.
when i joined the fed i've never asked
you
where you grew up i grew up in montreal
canada
um my parents actually lived in south
america and moved about two years to
montreal before so my brother and sister
are colombian and
i'm canadian um so i always joke around
and i said i'm like the most
non-partisan person because i don't vote
republican or democrat i don't vote
period
i love that gets me out of jury duty
though so you
did you attended university in montreal
as well i attended concordia university
in montreal which was uh one of the two
english language
universities was montreal's half french
half english when i grew up now it's
about
60 percent french 40 so presumably you
speak french
i do remo if you if you prefer that way
i had my bachelorette party in montreal
i've been to a number of bachelor
parties in montreal but let's stop there
yeah well we'll we'll end it there let's
just say that i thought it was a
cute city in canada until i had my
bachelorette party there
uh in any event we'll we'll move on
let's put this away in canada we have
toronto the good
and as i refer to as montreal the
naughty huh
yeah it would make people in vegas blush
but um
so reese's i'm very proud to be
montrealer
um yeah i'll tell you a funny story
about
anyways about the little french i know
saving me
one night in montreal when it was slowly
well no is no in english or in french
exactly my seven years of french came in
handy finally
um so i have to say
i i'm not used to picking up the
financial times
and seeing your byline i was kind of
floored and then
the the title is
the worrisome 1999 vibe
to markets and you you've been on the
right side
of being bullish for a very long time
to to the credit of of everybody who
who's fortunate enough to
to read your research and and and see
your views
why do you feel like it's 1999 again so
we're looking at our sentiment factors
in particular we have something we call
our panic euphoria model
there are nine factors in that model
that kind of interact together
um we'd done this testing when i moved
into strategy role back in 2001
the one thing we felt we were really
missing was kind of a good sentiment
gauge
so you created the panic euphoria model
we we took something that existed and we
kind of modified it
but we backtested about 70 different um
different inputs that you could look at
to see
if they had predictive power so for
example everybody talks about the
volatility index from the fix
it's a coincident indicator it's not
much of a predictive indicator
now people say when it's sitting really
high it's predictive when it's sitting
really low it's predictive too
similarly you're between 10 and 20 on
the vix and you're between 30 and 40.
on the fix your for probability outcomes
for success in markets
are about the same everybody thinks
they're wildly different where you don't
want to be is between 20 and 30 that's
kind of
the ugly spot but either either if
you're coming from high degrees of
volatility low degrees of volatility
once you cross that 20 or 30 threshold
depending upon the direction
um that's not a good place to be um
so in general though we backtested 70
factors found 20 that had predictive
powers and then we started doing things
like
permutations combinations because often
things can interact
because that's the real world right we
don't live in a world where you know
if a occur b follows but we do live in a
world a b c
d e f and g are there h is probably the
next letter
right the pattern is telling you
something so we started doing a lot of
work and give you an example two of the
factors in the model
are short interest and margin debt so if
you have high degrees of margin debt
people are borrowing a lot of money to
buy stocks
usually a contrarian indicator you know
people are a little too bullish
um if you have high short interest
they're essentially betting the markets
will go down
right so again contrary indicator if
they have to cover their shorts the
stocks are going to go up
what happens when you have both margin
debt and
short interest up at high levels
well that's the signal you're getting
going two different directions
so what i found over my years on the
street over
35 years that people have narratives and
they just remove the one that doesn't
fit the narrative right you look for
confirming evidence
because none of us want us we want to
you know deal with what
my psychology professors years ago told
me was cognitive dissonance
so we just get rid of it and we just go
with our story we don't really want that
we want
what's really going on happening telling
us what the sentiment is and then we'll
build the narrative
not the other way around sure so follow
the data so
panic euphoria is euphoric territory
the last time it was this high was back
in 1999 into 2000
okay um and the last time that it didn't
signal a
shorter term pullback was again in 1999
into 2000. so
we've gone for six months in euphoria we
were at levels in
uh february and march that were above
what we even saw
in the peak of the tech bubble so these
are the things that are getting us a bit
nervous now
it's different i i need to be very you
know careful even though
i'm more cautious i'm not terribly
bearish
um in fact i was telling a media outlet
that's always embarrassing i said well
if you guys can feel you know terribly
uh
convinced of calling or designating me
tagging me a bear
at least call me a teddy bear you know
at least i'd be lovable
right because we think it's kind of more
of a 10 pullback kind of thing not a 20
30 10 percent pull back it's not
going to be 1999 2000 leading into 2001
right because of three things one we're
exiting a recession we're not entering
one
okay two the fed was raising rates for
15 months
into march of 2000 before we started to
see the market crack
that hasn't raised anything if anything
they're telling you that no we're not
going to not going to we'll see
how it really plays out but and the
third one is
today a lot of those big mega cap stocks
that we talk about
tend to be dominant market positions
generating lots and lots of free cash
in 1990 and 2000 these are dot-com
burning cash
trying to get first mover advantage
right so as soon as the cash dried up
so did their business plans so we don't
have the same
constituency and framework that we have
but again it doesn't preclude you can't
pull back
it's just you're unlikely to have the
kind of really bear market
environment well i mean we've i mean
the nasdaq i think is down around six
percent maybe
i want to say and that's been pretty
that's been pretty painful for a lot of
people
so it's been painful in specific areas
like for example you look at stocks
they're down 30 40
within nasdaq and they tend to be more
in the small mid cap software stocks
they were trading 20 times revenues
already they were given like
every piece of credit possible for
their valuations and to some degree when
we had
coveted hit we had this reaction in
terms of
um shelter in place work from home and
it benefited a number of companies
business models significantly sure
so their business really took off and as
the stock prices were reflecting that
more people came as uh these stock
prices going up got to buy them because
they're right and going higher momentum
momentum and price momentum be gets more
price momentum people come in they're
going to sell to somebody you'll pay
even more
in the future and that's what they kind
of believe so these stocks probably went
too far
and now we're coming back to earth so
i'm curious now
so short interest margin debt what are
the other seven
no that's you're gonna test me
remembering that kind of a cliffhanger
here so oil prices are one
um because they tend to have some
interesting impacts on markets
uh actually gasoline prices specifically
um
we have the put call ratio we have the
average of investors intelligence in the
american association of individual
investors
so we do have one cent like real pure
sentiment metric in there
uh we look at the premiums that people
pay for puts versus calls
how deep in your pocket are you willing
to dig to buy protection
you know it's kind of if you want to
call it it's a tell yeah yeah right if
you're really really concerned about
something
if you're not concerned about crime
you're never locking your doors
but if you are concerned about crime
you're going to lock your doors with 16
locks you're going to get an alarm
system cameras
all that kind of stuff so it's a
question of what investment are you
willing to put in if you're really
really worried in terms of that premium
for a put versus a call we look at
money market fund levels so what's cash
on the sidelines if you want to call it
that um is another indicator
and don't i'm trying to think of i've
said them all at this point oh
new york stock machine trading volume
relative to nasdaq trading volume so if
there's
more speculative trading in the nasdaq
you can also pick it up through
that activity interesting um
i think i got them all but if i missed
what i apologize no no no i i think you
did as well
we have seen an appreciable uptick
in options activity in the i mean well
headed into valmageddon and
powell's first days in office and when a
short volatility fund basically went
away etf
uh there really wasn't that much retail
participation
in the market that's changed so look
there was some of it related to the to
the pandemic and stimulus checks
and people couldn't go into the sports
betting sites
yeah um there wasn't sports right so um
i guess you could potentially have you
know
gone into something like a cricket match
in pakistan or something but
generally speaking there wasn't you know
the activity so people
you know like the david portneys of the
world who are saying hey get in on this
and
people are sitting at home and let's
give them something to do
um that's very different today but i
think that kind of started some of that
fairly inexperienced retail
participation
and that was very diplomatic and oh look
you
you know um i still remember doing an
options trade many many years ago in my
early days as an analyst
and i ended up really working up so
short on the computer stock it worked
out really well
and my boss came in the next day because
he saw the trading sheets and he said
hey i want you to join oa from now on
and i go oa
because yeah options anonymous you're
going to lose money doing this
and of course i want to see you know
he's an old dude you know and and
he was right i lost money money to
option trades so
um so i've kind of personally sworn off
them but um
but i but i you know you learn through
experience that's what i'm saying that
that suggests that
that this very young generation of
investors
is going to kind of learn on the job we
all do
in any in any job we do you know there's
on-the-job
uh training and some of that tends to be
pretty painful
right so i do worry about people going
to areas they don't really understand
and if they have quote-unquote beginners
luck they
then believe it's their smarts right
because everybody's a genius in a bull
market
um not so many when when the tide goes
out you see the swimming
you know naked so you know those kind of
things worry me a little bit
i don't think it's as bad as some people
suggest we've seen in some areas mean
stocks for example
sure um and again you're looking at
companies that have
real issues and and you've got some in
my opinion some manipulative activity
that could be
exaggerated when i think of back you're
talking about the bubble days right
about yeah
9 2000 we had chat rooms where people do
things now it's on
you know it's on steroids because you do
it in social media across millions of
people
and and people get caught up in this
because they get excited by and they
make a little bit money and they get
more excited
um so things like small lot you know
option trading is a little bit
disconcerting but it's just another
reflection of money
trying to find a place to go and they
don't like earning 10 basis points in
the bank
did did we remind me uh did we have
cult figures back in 1999
the way we do today i mean it seems like
there's there's kind of this worship
element there were there were but the
cult figures were generally running
companies so a lot of these dot-coms you
know
that were exciting and we mean you know
everybody knew pets.com and
things like that um and we knew who they
were and we could argue we have some
cold figures today
as well in the corporate world sure
um so we keep reading about the
semiconductor shortage
i mean you can't every other headlines
about the semiconductor shortage in the
auto industry and
the effect it's having global supply
chain disruptions and you can't get
product you know can't get production up
high up
but you so you recently made a fairly
controversial call
on the semi sector so we downgraded them
back on april 9th um and our reasons
were
earning survision momentum was really
really good and probably couldn't get
much better
90 of all estimates up to the upside
historic history says
that doesn't sustain itself eventually
you can still go down to 87
still the majority of revisions are
positive right but it's a negative delta
in other words you went from up 90
and it's only up 80 so that means it's
10 worse
markets care about the rate of change as
well right
so that was one of the reasons our
valuation work also was suggesting that
we needed to pull back on them
we'd been overweight them they were
great stocks they outperformed
meaningfully
anyway something like 2600 basis points
in the prior year so they were great
they rewarded us handsomely um but our
valuation metrics don't look at it as a
cheap relative to history or things like
that
it's more of if the stock is trading
let's say an evd battal of eight the
stock go up or down thereafter
if it went to nine did it go up or down
thereafter um
if the pe was 25 and it went up then
it's not expensive it's just telling us
the stocks are poised to
right to generate returns so we have
models that we've looked at
in every single industry group which
have been the five or six most
predictive
and then we build the model of those and
right now you're sitting at an elevated
position
intimating under performance so we're
saying okay look you know
let's let's let's count some of our
chips
yeah let's take some money off the table
sure um i'm making more fun of the chips
and no you're thinking gambling
terminology and i'm not allowed to talk
about that
um so uh talk to me about
the shift in the last 20 years
towards really passive forms of
investing
versus active investing and then what
role has the 401k played
so two ways of thinking about it number
one there's nothing wrong with passive
investment vehicles i tell my my
children for for their 401ks do that
don't don't sit there trying to pick
stocks
it's it's not something you can do as a
part-time job
right sure you know i i i use a
different reference point which is if
the tile falls off my roof
i could go up on that roof and you know
take a hammer nail knock in
the tile but if i fall off the roof
because i'm not really adept at doing
this
i could break my neck right um so the
risk reward doesn't make sense
pay the guy a hundred bucks you know to
do it for you
and similarly i think people work really
really hard for their money during the
day
and they shouldn't be sitting there at
you know eight nine o'clock in the
evening and say okay i'll do some
web searches and i'll you know risk my
hard earned money
right so for them you know i think
generally speaking you know
passive products like etfs make fair
amount of sense i use them when i go
internationally because i can't do the
work on you know what's happening in
thailand right so or argentina or
something i just i don't speak the
languages i don't
understand the local cultures the
accounting systems make a difference
um so i think it's a perfectly
reasonable product to use it's it's an
efficient product
in terms of the cost right okay relative
to mutual funds and things like that
um but on the other hand active
management has its benefits too if you
have good money managers
so so there's still a role for us
there's definitely the best
you know i'm going to share two fun
statistics
and it may shock people and i do it
almost to shock them
in the fourth quarter last year
37 of the s p 500
beat the market by more than 10
percentage points
okay so if the market was up 10 percent
37 percent of the constituents so you're
almost talking close to 200 names 1867
names right
beat the market and they were up at
least 20 wow
okay if you look at the first quarter
performance
32 of the s p 500 constituents so again
another 160 names
beat the market by more than 10
percentage points and there's this
obsession
almost with five or ten names that this
is all that's
all the market right no no there's a lot
of good stock making you could have done
even if you forgot about those 510
minutes so there's always been a role
for stock picking the problem is
you have to avoid the losers too and
that's harder um
and even if you look you you may have a
loser that you that you couldn't help
right you you bought a stock because you
thought the new management that came in
was fabulous and they're really really
great and they're going to turn this
business around
they've done it before you know and you
have a lot of faith in this management
team and
god forbid you know the plane that
carrying the ceo crashes into a mountain
yep and your whole story just got
destroyed so did this person's family
but but i'm i'm saying the
the notion of you could have done all
your research and still had some
horrible luck
in in terms of your stock picking so i
you know i i don't sit there
liberally saying you have to avoid the
losers because sometimes it's out of
your control
right but the the the notion that stock
picking
can make a ton of money is still very
very much the case
it's never gone away it's been one of
the best you know if you go back
decades it's been one of the best ways
to make money is so i've always felt
there's a role for that even as we've
moved towards more passive vehicles
and for 401ks again it's easier for
people not to have to sit there and
start
trying to pick stocks and being that
brilliant because most of us aren't
you know you know i'm married 36 years
my wife tells me that pretty regularly
i'm not that right
she's generally right but just don't
tell my clients
um so
by the same token you in one of the
recent pieces that you wrote
you said that we really couldn't hide
behind
the 401k movement as we might have been
able to
in 1982. so what we're really talking
about is
is household equity exposure so if you
look at the federal reserve board data
stuff you're familiar with from your
days um
so there's a there's a segment in there
looking at
the household sector which is your
retail investor individual investor but
it tends to skew to wealthier people
because everyone wants to own the assets
right
um that their exposure to equities as a
percent of their financial assets are
near 50-year highs if not at 50 or
higher in this minute
stocks have not we always get data with
a lack
which means they're pretty fully
invested so over the past year or so
from the bottoms in march of last year
the equity market globally has added 50
trillion dollars of assets
it's a staggering amount a trillion
would be staggering 50 trillion this is
you just mine can't comprehend that but
that's
bumped up their equity weighting as
those stocks appreciated and they don't
they're not devoid
of investment participation right
they're fully invested
in 1982 83 i think 84 was the low
equity investing is a percent of finance
or equity holdings a percent of
financial losses were really really low
yeah so that was an incredibly starting
point as you buy stocks you bid them up
by price right too much demand none of
supply price goes up
and that's what they did and now if you
look at the future
based on that the returns over the next
10 years are unlikely to be that good
based on
when you've had these kind of levels of
of
investment proportions um
so there's arguments that people have to
use the 401ks today
as a way of building their retirement
because you don't have the fine pension
program anymore
right right but i could have made the
same argument 1990
90 and i could have made the same
argument in 2000
and we still had some tough years so i
think that that argument
you know people had to do that already
two decades ago
by the way it's hard to even think about
that for a second but the tech bubble
was more than 20 years ago so you have a
whole new generation of investors
of young people who never have no idea
it ever happened
right because if it didn't happen if
it's not in your memory
it kind of didn't happen well by that
same token
um you've got several generations of
investors who've never seen rising
interest rates
so that's that's the biggest debate on
the street okay which is are we going to
get inflation
are we going to get higher interest
rates and i would say they're three
buckets the way i think about it
okay i can't i can tell you others do
there's the transitory bucket
and the fed speak there's the
what i call stickier inflation bucket
the one i'm kind of
sitting in and then there's the third
one which is regime change
so what you're talking about a little
bit is regime change the idea of the
last 35 40 years
of disinflation some volcker killed it
is going to reverse
and the reason it reverses might be that
we go from just in time to just in case
inventory like
we saw with ppe and not being able to
get it when we needed it right
we need more chips for example so do we
really want to
rely on overseas supply chains that
might get disrupted
and what people forget is when the
fukushima earthquake and
tidal wave hit it knocked out chip
production as well for
certain components needed in the auto
industry a number of years ago
um so do we want to have supply
disruptions like that or do we want
something a little bit more domestic
um which will be more expensive than if
we do it overseas
workforces here are just a little bit
more expensive than those in sri lanka
um you know do we want to have boats you
know piled up at the
at the port of los angeles and wait a
month to six weeks to have the month off
loaded
or does that screw us up a little bit in
terms of our ability to to meet
um demand so there's that argument that
we might move some stuff back here
to have that support there's a second
argument around
kind of social justice issues that we
need to get more people back to work
um and and it becomes not just a a
political dynamic but it also has it's a
real cultural and
societal one so there's this desire to
do this and
you know and is there
anti-globalizations that are armed
and hollowed out right the companies i
used to cover back in the midwest where
they moved production
not not just necessarily i mean there's
this idea that somebody should have left
ohio and michigan illinois and moved
to thailand or taiwan or whatever or
china but but it's also a lot of it
moved to tennessee
and it moved to alabama and louisiana
and all these work states
right um texas at much lower cost
you know the to the businesses you know
when i covered some of these big
industrial companies they're paying 60
an hour you know you kind of uaw wages
and
um even if you just graduate from high
school you got and got a
you got a broom you were being paid that
as opposed to running a machine
you know right right right high skill
right it didn't matter
and even you know so when they started
moving those jobs down opening
facilities in the south
um you started seeing the union saying
hey let's do it you know
do a double or dual wage system for the
new entrance and then earn their way up
which made a lot of sense and was again
trying to retain the jobs
in places that sounds like a good way to
control your costs
corporates were certainly in favor of it
but but um even the unions understood
what was happening and said we want to
maintain these plans in places like
you know elgin indiana and in champaign
illinois and stuff like that so
we didn't want it all going down you
know to asheville
right and as a result i think there's a
tendency to think it's all offshoring
that wasn't necessarily the case right
again i used to cover industrial
companies so it's an area that i have a
lot of passion about a lot of
strong feelings on but even outsourcing
the way we think about it and how we
lost all these manufacturing jobs
well if one of these manufacturing
entities decided to move their payroll
system
to somebody like paychecks or something
and you take care of it for us because
you have
efficiencies that we don't have in terms
of scale
um those left an sic code that was
manufacturing went to services
even though they were doing the same
services job so some of the job losses
even
mckinsey's done work on this and that's
like that trying to understand
how much really got offshored how much
hot onshored and how much spot
you know moved to again oh there's
another efficient system there's also
automation
yeah it's that i mean that's
revolutionized a lot of areas of
industrial
think of it think of it this way to me
the simplest way to think about
automation
we don't we don't have to get really
cool and technical and robots and
all that kind of stuff um you have
an answering machine that answers your
phone
right if somebody calls you on your
iphone it goes to your voicemail
there isn't the secretary taking your
message and you want to talk about the
substitution of capital for labor that's
about as simple as it gets
and it happens in so many other ways but
i'm saying that just knocked out i mean
now if i want
if i want to watch a movie i just i just
look look at the movie
on amazon search for it and download it
i mean i used to have to oh you gotta
get the new
the new like the new uh remotes that you
talk to
you don't even have to search there's a
remote i can talk about there's some
remotes you can document
and just say i want to see xmovie and
it'll find it for you it'll come back
and say it's on
if you have amazon prime and it's free
go for it if you want to pay more we'll
charge it
you know you have that i thought i was
going to walk away the nine components
of the panic euphoria model instead i'm
going to go find this
remote control i've seen it advertised i
don't know i don't own it either
but but my point is now people are you
know
a teenager is like what's a vcr just but
just keep in mind that i was the family
remote control
okay because i was the youngest so with
my brother or my sister or my parents
go turn the channel in turn the channels
i was the human
yep i was the bot well before they came
out with a device
we had a tv when i was growing up that
was in one of those
that was in one of those wooden cases
that looked like furniture perhaps i
still remember when we got our first
color tv it was like yes
we're cool i remember i guess i'm aging
myself but yeah i remember i remember
twice there was amazing mighty mouse i
was always i always woke up like
at 5 30 in the morning on saturdays and
my parents were always like
go turn on mighty mouse watch the black
people go back to sleep
and then they go back to sleep exactly
um
but but back to the 401k thing so i
don't think i don't think
again because asset price has gone up so
much 401ks for those who haven't been
polluted
for those who haven't i i worry about
them
in in terms of where we are in 20 30
years you can see the stats
that's what the average person has i'm
kind of shocked at what baby boomers a
lot of baby boomers don't have
yeah no look i i you know i guess my dad
taught me a long time ago
you know that you got to save your money
you can't just spend it
so that's the one thing i keep trying to
tell younger people
is that they they want to get rich quick
they believe that they get i mean
they're pretty they're pretty
assertive on my twitter feed but i'm
like no you have to save the money first
first you got to save the money it's
hard because we all there are a lot of
reasons why it's hard
is we we live in an instant
gratification society is part of the
problem
um and again i'm as guilty as anybody
else of that
um you don't get a body like this by
chance you have to work at it
so if there's that burger there and that
piece of you know chocolate cheesecake
it kind of gets eaten
so back to your three buckets of
inflation
so the first bucket we were talking
about which was the federal reserve
board's kind of
transitory transient kind of thing i
believe investors
when they hear adjectives they put
numbers to it
so if a business the corporate
management team were to say in a
conference call our business is up
slightly right
you kind of say it's up one two percent
and they say modestly up three four if
they say moderately mid single digits
that they significantly probably getting
double digits
right they don't say that but we
attribute
numbers to those words so when you hear
the words transitory i think for most
investors i think several months
yeah and it goes away and and part of
that is the pandemic related base
effects
start to moderate right so your year
over year jumps and inflation will start
to slow
theoretically that starts in june right
with the june day
so i'm saying that which means you get
in july right so
it's several months and then it
dissipates the problem is that some of
the issues that we're talking about
in terms of you mentioned ships before
so those chip shortages um
the the idea of of um
of labor costs so if you look at the
national federation of the defendant
business their biggest problem
is quality of labor they don't have the
right fits for the people it's not
you know this this whole discussion
around is it the enhanced unemployment
check see if you can feel that work i'm
sure there's some people
doing that but not generally um you know
there's some people who are fearful of
coven
and going back and getting sick there's
an answer there called get vaccinated
but
whatever right yeah um and there's a
third one
which is women who can't get their kids
back to school
and that's a huge number and you know in
that sense
they want schools open so they can get
back to work it's not they don't want to
come back to work but again that might
have been a cashier at a store that's no
longer reopening
and they don't have the skill set to do
operate a machine
shop and work in a lathe in the machine
shop in waterloo iowa or work in coding
in silicon valley or drive a truck you
know with a big
with a big rig um they may you know they
can't
they cannot work on a construction site
you really want people who are untrained
to be
you know an infrastructure site with a
jackhammer probably take their foot off
so you know they're we we have skills
mismatches too
and we've had a skills mismatch mismatch
for a long time
but i feel like the challenge is yeah
and now we have countless brick and
mortar
employees with retail sales experience
and that's about it
look it's not if some of the retail
sales experience can go to work in a
hotel pretty easily and you know stand
behind a desk and say can i check you in
right mr mrs i mean you don't need to be
a skilled
again operator of the machine tool to do
you know that's a different kind of
skill set you know it's like yeah
welding is one of
is a really high-end skill set welders
make a lot of money
i know they do and yeah you wouldn't
want to give me one of those torches
yeah i mean i would actually body part
off my old boss richard fisher that was
his
favorite example welders underwater
welders the guys who fixed pipelines off
the gulf coast
they make at least so these are navy
frogmen former navy frogmen who learn at
a weld
and they get paid you know six figures
wow
usually starting with a three or four
because
it's really dangerous to go after a
hurricane under there and try to
reconnect those those gas lines
um i know where i'm going to send my
kids it's it's it's i mean i i shouldn't
i'm going to say because i
just often say things i shouldn't say
but i also tell my son as a doctor in
psychology that he shouldn't become a
plumber and my wife says why
did you don't do that and i said because
i think he'll make more money cleaning
crap out of people's toilets than other
brains
[Laughter]
and but they say that as a joke but i'm
not
actually joking no i mean if you think
about the average age of an electrician
in this country or i mean
when i was in high school i mean there
were the guys in shop
there was shop try and find shopping
in a high school today no they're
probably doing programming somewhere
coding
but which is fine and there's nothing
wrong with that but we don't have
mechanics we don't have
uh electricians we don't have plumbers
and you know you try getting a
contractor to show up
when they say they're going to show up
at your home so
these are you know these are really good
jobs get paid really
well but we have a lot of people don't
have those skills so the skill set
issue is a real problem and we're going
to spend money on training we're going
to have to
to get people there but that doesn't get
resolved overnight no
i'm saying we can't remedy some of the
issues so i was talking about the nfib
data
um historically when the nfib is telling
us small business people are telling us
that quality of labor is a big problem
within six to 12 months you have
significant wage increases
so i'm hearing it now i was talking to
somebody recently
the family office that they own a bunch
of hotels and
they need to fill 200 jobs and offering
thousand dollar signing bonuses and only
three people signed
yeah right um you know they're
they're they're people trying to find uh
how you know home builders are trying to
find people who work on their you know
on their
sites to put up new homes because we
have we have a severe shortage of them
yep you don't have the people they're
not available so i think these are
issues that aren't transitory they could
stick around for nine to twelve months
if you need copper it'll take three
years to put up a new copper mine
so these supply issues don't get
resolved as quickly and that's why i
call them sticky
now you might sit there in nine months
and say you know we're going to replace
copper with
plastic or aluminum or something like
that in that
in that specific application yeah you
might say i'm going to bring on some
robots if i don't have enough people
but again this is not something business
can do literally overnight
yeah i was actually i read a headline
that a major manufacturer was
closing a plant and moving it to mexico
that was the first time i'd
seen one of those headlines in a long
time um having
been an industrial analyst years ago the
quality of labor
and product out of mexico has not been
as good as the quality they would always
have to bring it back and redo it
um and so we'll see look there are a
number of great machiadoras that
probably do fantastic work
but i i just remember that my experience
was kicking out and saying
that didn't work out so well last time
so wage inflation that's that's
that's a big boogie man it's 60 percent
of corporate cost
yeah that's what we have to remember if
you're if your transportation costs went
up
deliver something and maybe it was cost
you three percent more it's one thing
but it's sixty percent of your cost
going up
you need to do something about it so
either we're going to get some
pressure to raise prices
and the other one would be if you don't
if you're not able to do so then you're
getting emergent corporate profit margin
pressure
well there's the issue of pricing power
right yep so some companies have them
some families don't and the ones that
don't are going to have to
be really really creative or their
margins will suffer so
it's kind of a tug of war are you
getting some inflation or are you going
to get some
margin margin marginal pressure right
it's one of the tip
is there's not kind of this easy narrow
path in between
and you know i i i'm very happy to not
work for the fed because i think
navigating this path is going to be very
difficult
everybody loves you when you're adding
you know boost to the punch bowl they
don't like you when you take away the
punch ball
no i mean just just the the very idea i
mean one's one cpi print and you know we
all lost our minds
uh and people were worried about the cpi
print you know they were they knew that
it was going to be bad and it still
shook them what if it's shaking them in
august and september
and that's a whole different issue
i think the the bond market may test the
fed kind of like they did in february
and march
if there's a little again i'm not
talking about regime change
but i am talking about a little bit more
persistent
stickier inflation than
transitory transient so what so
what can the fed do
i mean housing is a i mean how housing
is an issue right now
look the fed's a bit boxed in i think is
the best way
and people have said that they put
themselves in a kind of an
uncomfortable situation and now they
have to kind of
i don't know very let's hope and pray
because it's too strong the term but um
but they better be right or they're
gonna get egg on their face and egg on
the
central bank space the most important
central bank in the world isn't the best
for us no and it's it's interesting to
me
that um that the whole financial
stability
issue has come to the forefront in fed
speak
so quickly and now the ecv is kind of
echoing the same it's
which is which is actually i'll give him
credit for that for even bringing it up
laurel brainerd brought it up in the in
the report but
it's usually too late though i
understand that but
they tried to avoid all of that 99
they just didn't talk about it you know
you had the original irrational
exuberance
right that was 96 right it was way way
ahead of its time yep and then that was
it and then once
and then took off i'm saying but then
when you got to
99.com frenzy
narrow word for the fed on this so i
gave them a little bit of credit at
least they wanted they want to be on the
right side of it in case
something bad happens we talked about it
if you paid attention or not is your
issue but we at least mentioned it
um they're not going to mention a lot
but they'll at least get some credit for
that
but it's also interesting to see you
know um
i'll say chair cherry ellen um treasury
secretary ellen almost
make a chair statement oh that was and
then pull it back a bit
and then you saw the fed said you know
in the minutes
the commentary around if things get
stronger than we would have to
react in the interest rate environment
and it's like you know big
big duh like of course that's part of
your mandate
so but it was interesting that they're
willing to even have that show up
in print yeah like they're aware
that this is a potential problem even if
they don't think it's going to be a
problem
well and they're starting to talk about
housing a little bit more so you can
almost
you can almost imagine that i mean
people people don't realize that it's 40
billion a month of mortgage-backed
securities
but prepayments have been insane
so you might have months when the fed is
buying three times that amount
in the mortgage-backed securities market
just to reinvest just to keep the stock
of mortgages uh where they are and it's
it's just a huge
influence right now and yet but yeah but
they always do that
i mean i i'm less than people who talk
about the feds manipulating the markets
right i've heard that comment and that's
their job they're allowed you know if
things get stuck
in you know in the markets the fed comes
in with a crowbar
and kind of gets it's unstuck that's
that's part of their job again if you
and i do we go to jail
but um i don't really have a problem
with that i think that is their their
charge
i think the the debate is have they gone
too far
okay and you know i'm not gonna i'm i'm
gonna leave it to my fixed income
strategies to talk about they're
they're far more um
knowledgeable and probably even more
eloquent about it than i'm ever going to
be
so i'm going to keep my mush up for once
so
but but you can speak to
balance sheets and
we know that the fed came riding to the
rescue of
the corporate bond market and they
should have look and they should have
when everything froze again this is my
point about the crowbar
when everything kind of really got out
of whack in march so you don't think qe
alone would have done it i mean they're
buying a hundred billion dollars a day
on on sunday so when i've talked to
former
central bankers um who i respect
significantly um
you know i've heard them talk about and
giving me different dates in history
where the
where central banks have gotten involved
to fix problems
that you know sometimes the traditional
metrics don't work and you got to be
that's why i was using the term probi
you really have to force it
because everyone's too scared to let the
markets function
properly and they are in that sense the
buyer of last resort
and once they stabilize they should be
pulling back
and let markets do their thing and
that's where again that's where i think
the debate is if they have they
overstayed their welcome
and if they then have to pull back do
they cause the problem that they tried
to avoid
and we'll see you know time will tell
one of the most
insightful comments i've heard recently
is that we are existing
at either end of of the distribution
that we live at the tails right now and
that that that's
that is what you said is that so bad let
me let me let me put it this way so most
businesses and certainly financial
institutions
um have this wonderful thing called vars
very variable
variability risk right and those tend to
be in the tails
the stuff that you deal with the 95
percent of the you know two standard
deviation type stuff
that's normal that's not where you have
the problem it's when you're in the
tails that you have the problem
so i always laugh when they do the vars
because they do it 95 probability
your problem isn't the 95 your problem
is the two and a half percent on the two
on the ends and therefore i never quite
understood
that kind of risk profile so i'm not so
sure it's that bad that we're living a
little bit in those
in those just because that's where the
problems tend to be
um so
talk a little bit about um the prospect
for earnings growth
going forward so it should be really
good um
it should be because the economy is
getting better companies have been
learned to be efficient all those kind
of things
um we saw the first quarter blast
through expectations i mean there's
beating expectations then there's
beating it by seven dollars
okay um more than seven dollars actually
and
but you can't set the bar pretty low
which companies
did you know we you always hate when you
listen to management team talking about
being
caught you know the cringe-worthy
cringe-worthy cautiously optimistic
terminology
um and they they kind of sandbagged
but nonetheless they weren't sure either
to give them some coverage it was huge
uncertainty i
agree and but now i think that there's a
change in that expectation now every
every corner should be blocked
is kind of what ends up happening in the
mindset of investors right and there's
there's kind of published estimates and
then there's kind of
in your mind estimates that are
generally above published estimates if
you just crash through them we used to
call it the whisper number
yeah we're not allowed to our lawyers
get crazy when we say that um so
hence i'm talking about the unpublished
expectations and not using that
particular term
um i'm you know i'm i'm very enjoyed at
avoiding the words that are going to get
me into trouble
and in that sense
i think the street is anticipating even
better numbers so we think the market
levels would argue for like 190 in
earnings for the s p 500 already
is the expectation built into the market
when street consensus is more like 183
so the market's already pricing in
better numbers um
and they were doing that before and
again we crashed through the numbers and
if we if you and i were talking a month
ago the numbers were probably more like
171 172
right not 183.84 and again seven dollars
of that is just
the first quarter catch up but but don't
you think
we're gonna start to see the effect of
some of these rising costs
yes so that was the time of the margin
pressure even if businesses
raise prices some of the stuff that's
going to go through
the revenue lines in the next quarter
two is stuff you already booked before
at lower prices their current price
protected
yep okay um and as a result the
increased costs
to the business will show up with costs
but the revenues won't carry
the higher prices maybe a couple
quarters from now that which goes
through the revenue line
is at the higher priced item but not
initially
so we could get some disappointment on
the margins on that front from our
perspective you know
again i can look for personal experience
you know my wife and i ordered a
wood a new wooden door for our front
door um
six months ago i think we're getting it
next week
so the you know
we don't have to pay more because we
paid for it six months ago but
we're paying a different way in terms of
when it gets delivered of course
right and you know that's the world
we're in
i mean there's shortages everywhere i
have a friend who's bought up a bunch of
gyms in florida
who wants to open up a chain of new gyms
as everything reopens he can't get
equipment
backlogs on you know on on bikes on
treadmills on weights everything it's
benches
you bring up uh fitness centers and i'm
gonna have a non-sequitur
uh uh what is your feeling about um
not anyone in particular of course but
what's your feeling about
uh s packs and cryptos and
so i i you know our panicky four models
in euphoric territory it measures
sentiment
and i think some of the stuff you've
seen around meme stocks around this
packs
around um crypto is just lots of
liquidity sloshing around looking for a
place to go
and a gen in again in this kind of
environment speculative activity can
occur
it's not that look sparks themselves are
not inherently bad
they've been around for a long time
right and the idea of giving smart
people money to invest in businesses
dedicated to turn around
or grow faster because they have good
management skills
is all fine it's when you have over 400
of them
hitting the market stars and supports
legends
a lot of the celebrities packs are kind
of an interesting dynamic
um you know
they amused me more than anything else
um you know people buy it
oh i got to you know i got to hang out
with so-and-so yeah
um i get to hang out with danielle so
it's it's all good
but the the but i think that the notion
of
money going to areas that probably they
shouldn't go into because they don't
really understand them
is worrisome okay and you know i'm asked
a lot about this stuff i have a 94 year
old father who loves to invest
and um he always asks me questions about
some of these things and
i know no matter how much i try to deter
him from doing
these things um he does some of these
things he's 94. yeah it's funny
this is fun uh and thank god his brains
function and his body functions well and
he's you know we should all have his
health
in 94. but um but but but i worry about
again he's
these are areas he's totally
inexperienced about and is willing to
kind of risk some stuff and
like i told dad just don't do it he goes
why and i said because i'd like to have
an inheritance you know
[Music]
when you go and um tell me how you
really feel
i know he laughs he gets he gets the
joke um
but it's you know
i to me it's just a reflection of the
sentiment
i'm looking for my get-rich-quick scheme
yeah i have a lot of uh people on my
twitter feed who call me a boomer which
i'm not
hey boomer hey boomer don't you know you
don't need to work i mean this
is common common um
that's right that's why i enjoy
listening my children complain about
if i understand how much diapers cost
and how much the
kids clothes costs because they grow out
in about four minutes and you know we're
working and we
were trying to keep up that and it's
like killing us and they're smiling
what's so funny
i said maybe you'll appreciate your
parents for once um
you know but but you know they they do
learn it as like you know it's it's
when you're 20 you want to live in
manhattan because you want to go party
and order
chinese food at three in the morning and
when you have kids at three in the
morning all you want is those kids to
sleep and not be woken up by the uh
you know the the fire truck going down
the street at the police arguments and a
garbage truck going down the street
mom and dad weren't idiots living in
suburbia and guess where my kids live
now
suburbia because they want their kids to
sleep yeah no i mean i can't tell you
how many
friends in the city who haven't been in
the city you know you just get older and
you
more wiser and more experienced you know
there's something to that i was watching
a bill maher
thing about um you know that when people
hey boomer and all things like people if
you learn something new every
day and you've lived 10 000 more days
than the other person
probably there's some wisdom there there
and he
i think he did this whole thing on 18th
34 year olds as the you know the prime
advertising
cohort he says you know why because
they're the most gullible people on the
planet
because i kind of enjoyed that it's like
bill
bill's making a lot more sense to me
almost every day
so you can't turn
bubble vision off of mute without
hearing
cash on the sidelines it is i mean
and it tends i mean at least in my
experience you tend to hear
it increasingly at kind of an inflection
point
because people are looking for a reason
to
they're looking for a defense well it's
more than that i i own it
and i want you to buy me at a higher
price so you need to cash on the
sidelines to you know
to be that next buyer but isn't there
always cash on the sidelines
true and the numbers that people cite
are actually wrong
okay so what they typically cite is
money market funds retail money market
bonds in particular
okay and it could be institutional money
market funds too
those corporates have money that they
can invest as well and they can buy back
stock
but there's if you look at the household
deposits numbers in the flow funds data
the fed
then the numbers explode you're like 16
trillion dollars of quote-unquote cash
um but a lot of cash is a grandma's
passbook savings account that's never
coming into the market
because grandma's 83 and if my grandma
loses money she can't get another job
right now and start earning to make up
for the losses so there are people who
aren't ever going to put that money in
and that's why that some of the cash
flows highlights never
enters the market yeah that and the fed
has very good
data that shows demographically that you
know it's
between 55 and 16 and 64 and
65 and 74 that that's where the bulk of
the savings
exists and and that's and including the
delta
it's not it's not identical it's not
even that different if you go to japan
again the money is
tends to go to the elderly yeah and the
young people aren't
um as wealthy but i i think that's
generally true because as you're young
you're not making as much money and you
need that money to pay for your rent and
all that kind of stuff
and as you move up in life you can
hopefully um
get ahead of that and put some money
away um
but but the notion of
that money also being there is pretty
interesting because that generation will
die out
well i mean that's my next question i
mean we have this massive
intergenerational transfer of wealth in
the next decade or two
um and or at least you're hoping i'm
kidding
i'm kidding i'm kidding my brother my
sister maybe i'm not um i'm sure he's
sure they won't say this
but um but the the
the idea of that intergenerational
transfer wealth when people worry about
where the young people savings are going
to be
it'll probably be inheriting their
parents wealth and again it may not be
that the mom and dad had this huge
portfolio
mom and dad lived in a house right and
that house was appreciated over the last
you know
30 40 years and when they get sold it's
worth you know they bought it for
50 000 now it's worth 300 400 000 and
right and that's a lot of money i i read
a statistic that
um that since the pandemic
retirees have actually traded up to
bigger homes
30 of them it was a it was a big survey
that was taken
but but retirees in general
aren't flowing into retirement homes as
they did generations ago they're they're
aging in place
look the good news is on the health
front there's a lot of bad news on
health
particularly the pandemic there's also
the good news is longevity has increased
people
can live um they're pretty
good lives even after they retire you
know it's not like
you're working next day or the rocking
chair you know can't remember anybody's
name it doesn't kind of work that way
um and so a lot of them are more they're
more travel
they may not be spending more on
clothing than furnishing
but they might want to go on a trip
somewhere and you know it's just
different they're going to experiences
especially especially domestically right
now yeah cause it's kind of hard to get
away
but um but i'm talking about over the
last 10 years not the most recent year
and they they actually have something
very much in common
with with general with the millennials
as they both my experiences
so what's interesting also is looking at
the the baby boomers who are retiring
um and their in most cases millennial
grand
children or grandchildren that they they
they have this kind of connection about
experiences that they'd rather spend
their money on experiences
so a lot more travel family trips you
hear a lot about these kind of fun
things
and and that's fine i mean they'll still
spend money but
typically older people don't spend as
much money as they were when they were
younger and therefore there'll be more
money to transfer to the next generation
over time so he doesn't get taxed away
taxes given
the concentration of stocks in the hands
of older investors
uh that is pretty unprecedented i mean
in terms of the concentration
will capital gains taxes matter depends
where they go
um i think they're people worried if
they go to full ordinary income
that it could have some negative
implications you might want to sell a
lead just to lock it in
at a lower tax rate or it depends again
if it's grandfathered to
january one or not and there's gonna be
all these kind of interesting elements
that we started
with um if it goes to twenty to thirty
percent probably less of a problem
you know um so we just don't know the
details yet
um it will stop all kinds of innovation
probably not either
but at the margin it should hurt because
tax policy does impact
people think about their activity i i
would say the
the bigger question is um the step up
if i bought my portfolio 20 years ago
and then i died and leave it to my kids
and there's a step up in the value
and that changes you know that could be
pretty significant
and people will make adjustments i i was
listening to a conversation about
uh coming from the white house about
this would be really really good for
charities
because people will donate tons of money
to charity um because they'd rather give
it to the charity and get
their name on the wall kind of thing
rather than give it to the government
right and get the tax deduction right
so i was thinking about that and this is
more stream of consciousness
and i'm not so sure that's the way it's
going to play out you know i think if
you're really really wealthy and you're
giving billions of dollars away
um you'll probably create foundations
yeah right
you know directly we've seen that
happening i mean i'm talking about
generations yeah way way back but we saw
that happening and carnegie foundation
the ford foundation i mean oh yeah all
these foundations are ground
the only difference is now you're going
to hire your kids to run those
foundations and pay millions of dollars
i'll transfer the money then but i'll
just do it a different way so i think
people will be very clever
about that and and the foundations every
expense that the
family has will be on the foundation you
know when you have to go to that
gala it's amazing how you have to take a
private chat
and things like that i mean people will
be
they're clever they're creative and the
laws don't preclude him
no so i mean i think the cpa community
right now is like yeah the tax code is
about to get even more complicated
and there'll be new tax shelters that
are created out of the loopholes that
exist in the next piece of legislation
yep there always
is that's the one thing i would really
be upset about is that we spend
all this creative activity on tax
shelters
it just seems like a waste of you know
really good brain power
yeah it's a waste of i mean my mother
always said you know if you want
if you want earnings capacity for the
rest of your life become a tax attorney
she's like you've got job security
forever just remember a lot of
congressmen and women and senators are
attorneys and what do they do when they
leave congress
become partners at law firms yeah so you
know you just have to think about what
people do
sure enough that whole running for
politics
there's another really good benefit of
being a congressman or senator
which is you get you know serve one term
and you get health care for life
not bad go pat toomey mr term limits
um so
winding down our talk i you know i
obviously the federal reserve was a huge
influence
in in my career and it changed the way
that i see the world it had to
after nearly a decade but how has
fed policy in the past 20 years
changed the way that you kind of model
change the way you forecast
not a ton and i know that sounds crazy
when i say it but
you care about interest rate levels and
you care about things like that in terms
of
actually quantitative easing right no no
no but so you look at funding costs
as an important element to return on
investment and when
what all it does is it lowers the bar so
that things that might not have made
sense in the past
make more sense to invest in today
because you don't need to generate the
same kind of return
right if i if my funding cost was ten
percent i need to make 20
it might if it's five percent maybe i
only need to take ten percent if it's
two percent may only need to make five
percent
you know and it makes you willing to
take on
lesser return because it's still better
than the fun than
what other people could put their money
at and i've seen that even with real
estate investing where people would
demand kind of high team like returns
for the risk you were taking of the
liquidity of that
right today they're generating six seven
percent and it's
fine they're crashing cap rates right
they're willing to do it um because
that's a great return relative to what
i'm making
elsewhere so that's all it does is it
forces
new investment into other areas and and
and potentially into speculative
activity
right because you're not getting a
decent enough
return to sit in cash so you're willing
to try a few things and take you know
you know basically you're doing a long
long bomb and you're hoping
it's a hillary you look at defined
benefits i mean they
they're increasingly in in private
equity
and very aggressive it's not even i i
sit on endowment board and you know we
have to think about how we
invest money for the institution and um
and to me that was like a great
experience because it's not something i
ever have to do before
so joining that has been a really good
exercise
and learning for me and what private
equity does and what
venture capital doesn't does that is it
can create much greater returns
it does mathematically but there's a
liquidity dynamic to it
or an illiquidity right to it sure
there's positives and they can get
day-to-day mark to markets
and their negatives in that if you ever
needed that money immediately you
couldn't get it
right so you have to measure in your
investment portfolio how you
you know how you want to think about
return against availability
and you you structure your portfolio
differently a little bit for that
and i think maybe that's where it would
you know where the fed policy changes
uh force you into different kinds of
instruments right i'd like to take
grandma to vegas
and get her some junk bonds but um so i
have one
final burning question
which is better being a father or being
a grandfather oh grandfather no question
my my my kids um and you've got i have
five i have five
and um i can't make most of the jokes
because they're inappropriate
but i'm gonna i'm gonna but i'm gonna
tell you this one where
so my wife and i decided it just ended
up being working out well for the
pandemic period um but we decided in
october of 2019
to put in a pool in our backyard and the
rationale for that was really the
grandkids would come over a lot
yeah right because they don't play in
the pool and even they got older
they leave again to teenagers they hey
grandma grandfather can can we bring our
friends over and do nothing
sure as long as you get to see our
granddaughter at that point when they're
teenagers they don't care about the
adults around them
but we'll get to see them because
they'll bring over their friends right
um
and you know i actually wanted i told
myself when they're teenagers i'm
putting like a microphone out there so
when you listen to their conversations
that'll be fun
but but giving me ideas
i've got teenagers it's it's a fun
concept that she shot it down
something about privacy invasion and
stuff like that i don't get it doesn't
like tech companies don't have to do it
by the way
but so we we decided to put this in and
um and it just so happened that
the pandemic hit right you know you beat
the pool wrestlers um so my kids were
saying like
we didn't get the pool hook you know why
are you putting it down i said for
granted
you love them more than austin's kind of
well you get to send them back well it's
if they become pain in the butt
so i i will let's do this i'll leave
your viewers with a
huge chunk that's somebody told me one
time ago um it's clean don't worry
which is well you'll get it the
the if you ever notice baby divers
going through the brand names of pampers
loves
huggies but the adult incontinence
products go under the name depends
they serve the exact same purpose so
what's the deal so somebody explained
very clearly if a baby soils themselves
that's the dirty part
um and you have to clean them up and
then you re-diaper them and you still
will hug them you'll still pamper them
you'll still love them but if it's an
adult it really depends if you're in the
will
well um i'm not sure that's the exact
note we want to end off on but
no no that's the note i'll never look at
depends
again and not think depends on if i'm in
the will
uh sir thank you you've taken so much of
your time
thank you this was great visiting um and
i
i hope we do it again in a year and you
can
maybe there'll be a sixth grandchild
we'll see maybe
i wanted my son to get married first
though there's there's a sequence that i
prefer
thank you tobias thank you very much
well
like i said at the beginning of speaking
with tobias that's about as close to an
exclusive as we could possibly
have gotten for down the middle uh
you've seen him on cnbc
you've seen him on bloomberg but in
terms of sitting down with them for more
than an hour
what a treat i really really hope that
you enjoyed
the time with tobias lefkovich please
understand that it is it was a great
privilege for
me and obviously hopefully it was a
great treat for you as well one of the
best thinkers
on wall street until next time this is
danielle demartino booth for down the
middle and don't forget if you haven't
subscribed please do so now
[Music]